PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are
your existing applications
holding you back?
Find out how you can use Anthos
to modernize your existing
applications and
accelerate performance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I am Priyanka, and
welcome to Anthos 101.
In many organizations,
legacy applications
can hold back
business initiatives.
While new applications
are being developed
using cloud-native technologies,
most existing applications
are still large,
monolithic apps that
run on proprietary
application servers,
incurring high licensing costs,
slow release cycles, and vendor
lock-in.
The lion's share of
existing apps in enterprises
are written in Java.
And according to a recent
study, 80% of companies
will continue to leverage
past investments in Java apps.
40% of companies will
modify legacy Java apps
for cloud migration.
And 79% will modernize
the Java apps
with cloud-native technologies
like containers and Kubernetes.
Organizations looking to
modernize a Java application
typically have two
goals in mind--
one, to adopt modern development
frameworks and architectures,
and two, move to containers
and adopt DevOps practices.
To achieve these goals,
Anthos offers a solid path
to modernize your
Java applications
to realize immediate
operational cost savings,
reduce dependencies on
higher-cost proprietary
software, and increase
software delivery speed.
We see enterprise
Java applications fall
in one of the three
categories, and each
requires that you take a unique
approach to modernization.
First category, applications
using modern frameworks.
These are newer apps written
on modern Java frameworks
like Spring Boot.
The next step for
these applications
is to take advantage of
Google Cloud-managed services.
Spring Cloud GCP lets
your developers easily
adopt Google Cloud services.
Build tools like Jib and
Cloud Native Buildpacks
provide an easy way to
containerize these applications
using well-known developer build
tools like Maven and Rattle.
Once containerized, you can
manage these applications
with Anthos.
The second category is
commercial off-the-shelf
applications.
These don't have
the source code.
For these types of
applications, Migrate for Anthos
allows you to move VMs from
on-premise data centers
to either VMs running
in Google Cloud
or to containers running
on Anthos GKE, a cloud
agnostic implementation
of GKE that
runs in multiple environments.
This lets you quickly
adopt a modern platform,
whether on-prem or in the cloud.
And especially useful if
you have a large number
of applications, as they can be
migrated with minimal effort.
Third category, applications
running on proprietary servers.
These are your Java
applications developed
in-house using older
frameworks and often running
on commercial proprietary
application servers.
Google Cloud provides
a two-step process
for modernizing
these applications.
First, use Migrate for
Anthos to quickly migrate
existing applications running
in VMs to containers on Anthos.
You can also migrate off
of commercial app servers
to open-source app servers
to reduce or eliminate
licensing costs.
Second, refactor and rewrite
migrated applications
to use modern frameworks like
Spring Boot and Spring Cloud
GCP, and move to a
microservice development model.
Java app modernization
journey with Anthos
leads to tremendous
cost savings.
By onboarding the Java
app to containers,
you see a 37% total cost
of ownership savings
instantaneously.
Then by automating with software
pipeline and refactoring,
you can see an
additional 78% savings.
There you have it.
With Anthos, you can modernize
your existing Java applications
and accelerate performance.
Ready to start your
modernization journey?
Schedule an application
assessment workshop
with your Google team.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and check
out the entire Anthos 101
playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]